you started streaming recently right
sydney oh actually
before i started doing youtube i tried
being a twitch streamer full time
no way really what for all like a good
like
what did you stream uh out stream mostly
resident evil
really i really like like shooting games
because it's like
no brain that was that was back when we
were living in thailand and
sydney like because of her visa status
she couldn't get like a proper job there
so she would like try to take any like
odd jobs or like contractual jobs that
she could i'm like on the side i was
like
well you don't want to be a youtuber
because she was still kind of scarred
from the leafy thing so i was like yeah
why not try streaming you know that's
uh so how did that go for you it
actually went okay
like i got five viewers and um actually
my mods now that are like man my discord
as well as like everything
are actually the people the five people
from that time oh really yeah
and um that's how you know they're real
ones
let's kill i want to grow my audience
and then guns like just try doing
youtube i'm like
[ __ ] all right i'll do it and then just
did youtube instead
so do you plan to like go back into
streaming streaming's actually a lot of
work isn't it like it's oh yeah
i was going to ask about that what do
you think about the whole streaming
versus youtube debate
because they always [ __ ] argue it's
like all streamers don't put any effort
in and they're vice versa
vice versa if your stream is hard like
streaming you like talk to people
constantly you'd like
be entertaining non-stop for hours and
hours like constantly like
it feels like you're being like you have
to be excited peppered energetic
otherwise you're boring
yeah it's like if you had to pick like
if you say you were you could be just
successful
in either career choice being a youtuber
or a streamer putting in the same amount
of hours which one would you prefer to
be 100 100 youtube i think i i do
youtubers yeah
just because streaming is i think every
day it's constant yeah
i i i think i find streaming easy like
i i can just chat [ __ ] for like five
hours no problem yeah but you're like
one of the most
extroverted introverts i've met like
like
there are times when i'm just like i
just don't want to talk
especially when especially when i'm
streaming my stream limit is two hours
after two hours i'm just like
man i hate talking moving my mouth is
just effort now i still love doing
24-hour streams i've done like
five i think in total that sounds like
torture that sounds like torture
the last eight or six hours are just
pure pain and the last two
are like you're a zombie yeah like you
forget i would be like oh i haven't
spoke for a minute i'm sorry chat
that's what it feels like though but but
it's it's good because it gets people
excited because they know that they can
just
turn it on but like i don't know i i i
find streaming
the i easy when i do it but the problem
is is that i don't know how i could do
it five days a week
i like that with youtube okay i can work
14 hours a day for a week if i want to
but i can also just
not work for a week if i've prepared
properly right and i really love that
flexibility
and i feel like with streaming even i
even i've started getting it a little
bit i'm like
wait why do they lose 200 subs yeah i
haven't streamed in a week yeah and then
it's like oh i oh [ __ ] am i getting that
pressure of a streamer where it's like
yeah i've got to keep myself you got to
maintain yourself right and it's i
it's almost like you're gamifying it but
it forces like
you see these streamers do like 12-hour
day the 12-hour streams a day
like four or five times a week and i'm
like that can't be healthy yeah
they're just built for that kind of
stuff right like it's it's they're just
built different
yeah they're just built different man
what can i say honestly like i i really
do think that
streaming like i i think i'm gonna i'm
gonna say this and i'm gonna probably
piss people off i think i think
streaming takes way less talent i think
it just takes
a lot of patience i think it takes a lot
of learning and effort like i think
anyone can be a streamer i think for
some things on youtube it's a lot harder
to succeed
um yeah i think youtube has become very
specialized i don't know i feel like
um i feel like it's like half and half
because i feel that with streamers like
to
stand out in this day and age you have
to be you have to have something about
you that makes you stand out that's true
whether it be like you have to be a v
like yeah all you have to be a youtuber
and it's even then it's just a matter of
time for vichy was get so oversaturated
that's that it's gonna it's gonna be
already happening yeah yeah exactly
right i mean that's why hotter life have
like uh um have a
audition period yeah like there's
there's it's no coincidence that
everyone in hot life is really really
good at being entertaining it's because
they [ __ ] audition for it i mean i'm
not saying that like
you know it it it requires no talent
whatsoever i just think the
the barrier of entry to i mean even
twitch is really hard to get an audience
on yeah i feel like youtube it's easier
to get to the first thousand subs
whereas on twitch it's hard to go from
zero to ten right that's
hard i just feel like with youtube
there's more opportunity for creators
because with streaming you are way more
limited in your ideas of what you can
do and not saying you can't do like
original ideas but you are way more
limited than what you can put in a
youtube video
per se that's true that's true but i
don't know i feel like youtube has
become
so competitive recently to be even
notable whatsoever you do
i'd argue twitch is like even more
competitive really you think so yeah i
think twitch is way more really
okay okay enough i would have no idea
how i would go about
growing myself on twitch if i wasn't
already established yeah yeah well
i wouldn't either yeah whereas on
youtube i'd be like maybe i can do
like an interesting video idea or like
right you know tackle a certain
topic and wait in a way that no one else
has because let's be real when it comes
to twitch
like discovery oh it's garbage it's it's
[ __ ] like people don't go on twitch to
watch vods yeah like that that's just
not how it's like as in like
to be a successful twitch streamer is it
the problem of i'm not entertaining
enough or the algorithm is [ __ ] me
like what what what's what's like or is
it it's a bit of both i reckon because
like again
it stems down to that whole thing of
like you know if you have more than 20
viewers
in a stream every stream then you're
technically in the top 10 of twitch yeah
right it's like it's there's just
anybody can do it but to maintain that
level of quality
throughout the entire time i think does
take somewhat of a talent right
there's a lot of streamers like between
20 and 100 that just like
you build up that that like audience of
just pure like
commitment yeah just like constantly
interacting with them
yeah yeah and i think to get to that
point is like just requires just
not being a dick and just dedication
because like i'll tell you one of the
big reasons why i was able to get into
like the v tuber scene versus like the
live streaming scene before like
youtube's came along it's because
what i couldn't get into about like
streamers is that there's they're
basically always streaming
right they could be like they could be
they're streaming eight hours a day so
you
you can tune in anytime you you want but
you don't know what they'll be doing
you know sometimes everybody's playing a
certain game then you know i get that
you can just leave them
on them on in the background but i like
having like a piece of content that i
know
i can watch so we're vtubers most of
their streams are like one hours or two
hours long
so it's just like very segmented so i
know like i know what i'm getting out of
avicii with stream you know they're
going to be playing for this set amounts
and you know it's it's on a schedule
they're going to be doing x
x show or play playing x game and i can
be like okay
i'm going to watch this vg for this time
and then i could you know
do something else whereas with twitch
it's just like do i want to put them on
in the background you know maybe maybe
not you know there's
there's nothing that inherently draws me
to their content
aside from if i really like that person
and also it's just so much easier to
like watch back on vods
on youtube because youtube is built as a
already
pre-recorded video service right so like
yeah
so it's just way easier to like go back
like if you missed a vtuber stream
then it's so easy to just go into the
channel and just see all the vods there
like a regular youtube channel yeah
right right whereas with twitch
looking through vods is a [ __ ] pain
in the ass because they've set it up so
shittily
that's that's why everyone has to
[ __ ] highlight this channel right
exactly yeah
which yeah i want to get as well
yeah i saw someone someone started
highlighting your twitch streams as well
yeah yeah they did they did and i want
to basically just
get one where i can just like you know
split the ad rep with someone so it's
like all right they just do it they get
the ad rev
yeah and then it's just you know yeah
make content more
because like i mean if i'm streaming i
may as well turn it into content right
like yeah if
and if i have nothing to do with it
great like i can just you know
yeah i mean it's whatever i mean i i
yeah i do think that twitch is [ __ ]
hard to get the ball rolling